the ending of Eva eisen's reveal the
Super Saiyan 1 transformation one piece
is gear 5 and Naruto confronting pain
there are moments for me and all shows
that make student series great and I
think the end of this battle is another
one of those everything we thought we
understood about the series has
ultimately flipped on its head
throughout this fight here so it's time
today we are diving back into Jujutsu
Kaizen and the most recent complete
section of the story more specifically
the decisive Gojo vs sakuna battle and
the uninhabited demon infested District
of Shinjuku
well I guess I need to kind of take
everything back to the exact moment
where the fight kicked off and of course
massive manga spoilers for anyone who's
an anime only and having to stumble
across this fight anywhoes as all of
these Sorcerers were lacking out
discussing how to give Gojo a boost of
confidence as it's the first time
they've ever really needed to do so Gojo
himself a company by Gramps and utahime
or with looks of determination then roll
up and get ready for battle with
everyone around filling his Aura Yuji
great to Sensei wholeheartedly and lets
him know that he can't even get close
because his techniques in the way goju
is slightly surprised by this but after
a moment ends up laughing while telling
his boy to give it to him causing Yuji
to jump up and slap his Sensei on the
back then following on the same path
every other sorcerer padded Gojo on the
back as he rolled through the group on
his way to the battlefield walking
through a skyscraper with Gojo now
ajichi knows that it feels like ages
since he was last here yet in reality
it's only been just over a month now
wanting to know what like the realm felt
like Gojo explains to him that the
president realm was like when you're mad
busy with work that it flashes in a week
however they're feeling so draining that
you'd never want to experience it again
after a few moments Gojo inquires about
the people in the basement of shibuyu's
metro station where all of that chaos
had started back in the Shibuya incident
Arc if like we're being specific that's
where Gojo came across choso Hanami and
jogo and they tried you know like
teaming up on him and whatnot even
though Gojo only fought them for a very
short period of time at least remnants
of Gojo's cursed energy that made cursed
Spirits avoid the entire floor which is
actually insane when you think about it
like this man is so strong his residuals
managed to secure off curse Spirits
which is I just I still can't fathom it
like I don't think anyone else is on
this level ajichi also reveals that the
people who were affected by a 0.2 second
domain are all fine and those who were
affected return to normal walking it
behind Gramps in otahime now Atop The
growth Gojo and ajichi arrive as the Day
of Reckoning has begun elsewhere a
roommate asks what time the fight is
going to take place twitch sakuna
reveals that they didn't really specify
a time but is as he says that he's able
to feel Gojo's Aura emanating in his
Direction back in the hallway and just
moments before they made it up to the
roof and Chichi confronted Gojo on why
he always wanted him to construct the
barriers for him turning back and
looking at his close friend Gojo tells
them that it's because he trusts him
more than anyone else now atop the roof
and slamming his hands onto the ground
in preparation for his barrier ajichi
just thinks on how he's someone who's
always fled no someone who didn't even
have the courage to flee and was given
the courage to run by a friend despite
everything ajiji braces himself and
knows that he must live up to Gojo's
expectations either that or die trying
in front of the two and while using her
curse technique called solo forbidden
Arena it's explained that any Sorcerer
of her choosing including usahime
herself will have their curse energy
reserved and output temporarily enhanced
as long as they remain within range to
excel at Jiu Jitsu is to excel at
subtraction the degree to which a
sorcerer can emit Cadence movement and
other elements that relate to the occurs
technique determines their skill and
ujahime leaves nothing out words
gestures dance music elevatingly simple
techniques that of a ritual boosts its
Effectiveness by 120 percent
udahime's curse technique allows you to
boost the chosen sorcerer's curse energy
and as Gojo himself also began chanting
to add to his own technique nine ropes
polarized light Crow and declaration
between front and back as revealed that
just like our girl Gojo has also never
left anything out and with the
combination of the Trio's curse in G he
shoots fourth his 200 Hollow purple as
goju's ability blasts forth sakuna
manages to take notice of it and throws
up his hands trying to block the entire
attack with the buildings all around him
exploding due to hollow purple zakona's
defenses are undoubtedly braged as the
building he was standing on is
completely demolished causing that to
fall to the ground below uramae who was
like next to sukuna at the time of the
attack has also not been seen since this
moment so like it correct me if I'm
wrong or anything but after this moment
she seemingly vanished from reality so
if she's either gone or she sneaked off
managing to like survive that attack
probably healing up somewhere either way
as these smoke slowly Fades it's made
evident that Judah ajichi's barrier
sakuna actually misread Gojo's first
move like even though he knew where he
was he didn't sense the insane curse
energy output until the last moment
bursting through the smoke sukuna with
one less hand somehow managed to tank
the first attack leaving the true battle
between history and today's strongest
Sorcerers to continue so skipping back
just before the blast sakuna and uramae
were located at the Shinjuku Center
which is around four to five kilometers
away from the Shibuya building Gojo was
currently on with his team having
strolled or probably just teleported
across that distance in a matter of
moments Gojo sets the brickles straight
and tells the king of curses that he's
the Challenger here the Challenger
though sukuna standing there finds it
are sleep pathetic that goja would stay
there after landing a surprise attack in
his eyes and as he brings his hands
together Gojo is no more than any fish
atop its chopping board one slightly
fresher but still a nameless fish
flaring up his curse energy sukuna just
remarked that it's time he starts
peeling back Gojo scales Gojo asks him
why he's still wearing that face and
guesses that sukuna's original thought
was to steal megami's body so he'd hold
back during the fight unfortunately for
him our man's been through a specific
set of training that allows him to go
all out on anyone who resembles any sort
of resemblance to the great toji
fushiguro considering that Gojo himself
trained Mega me he probably knows
exactly how many hits this student could
take before he dies and given that
sakuna had survived death while
possessing juji's body God you thought
it would be prudent to only start
worrying about migami's welfare after he
kills the person in control initiating
the conflict the duo darted each other
both just narrowly dodging each
successive strike dropping to the floor
just out of range of sakona Gojo flicks
out his hands straight into his
opponent's nut sending them shooting
into the side of a nearby building and
out the other side crashing into some
stairs behind it hitting up he's
instantly Rest by Gojo who stomping in
this direction proceeds to kick him in
the gut so he's perfectly placed in the
middle of an overpass Bridge platform
continuing to stomp down Gojo collapses
the platform sukuna was on making his
footing extremely unstable taking the
opportunity to catch him off guard Dojo
activates his infinity and levitates the
bridge into the sky before tossing it
directly at a large skyscraper resisting
the force of the platform sukuni uses
dismantle or what I assume to be
dismantled to cause this structure to
collapse then making it over to a nearby
roof in the flesh of an eye sakuna pulls
up his hand and sends a massive slice
using dismantle to cut the building
directly behind Gojo in half while they
are man turning around to look at it
zakuna quickly rushes him thrown a fat
right Hawk that catches Gojo off guard
however as the punch connects with his
Infinity he decides to deactivate his
technique in order to physically take
sakuna inside of the collapsing
structure following him up the hallway
Gojo quickly opens a door for a moment
that blinds the two from seeing exactly
what ability they're about to throw at
each other catching them both off guard
though the building crashes into the
ground below bringing the previously
intense fight to a brief pause walking
out of the debris will all of this smoke
slowly starts to disperse Gojo jokes
that well he's just gonna pin all of
this destruction on sakona once he gets
out of here sukuna though points out
that he really can't say anything
quickly making God you'll realize that
Meme is actually streaming this entire
fight to the world
when it comes down to Gojo's Limitless
technique it allows him to be completely
Untouchable to get around this and in a
similar way to what Hanami and jogo did
sukuna is using domain amplification to
neutralize his curse technique confuse
slightly on what domain amplification is
he explains to everyone while they watch
the fire that he saw something similar
in mikamaru's footage he pretty much
said like what I exactly said before
about Joko and an army using domain
amplification to nullify like Gojo's
technique and everything Curry points
out that it does seem like Gojo's domain
has been neutralized but he's still
confused how the old G kusakave lets
them all know that it's more of a
refined version of a simple domain if
one sheaths himself in a domain without
imbuing your own curse technique you'll
allow the opponent's technique to flow
into that empty space thereby
neutralizing Earth Angel points out that
the main drawback to domain
amplifications is that you can't
simultaneously use your own enemy
Technique No One not even sukuna is an
exception to this rule so and her eyes
if sukuna has another way to deal with
them unless other than domain amp then
Gojo will 100 lose confused on whether
don't just use the domain expansion
maybe what inquires as to why she knows
that immediately following their domain
once technique becomes unstable so oh my
God so it would make sense for sukuna to
challenge your domain first Carrara
notes that it is easy to say there but
depending on the outcome of that domain
battle the fight would be over which in
both of the girl's eyes is the correct
battle strategy Yuji though having been
told something by Gojo reveals that he's
pretty sure the domain sure had effect
negates Gojo's technique to begin with
picking up wee-wee wonders if it's
because sukuna doesn't think he can win
in a domain expansion against Gojo still
shoko points out that yeah you are right
but Gojo probably would have opened one
if that was the case so she finds it
hard to believe that Gojo wouldn't be
able to foresee that as well standing
near chosu Ponders the question of what
would happen if God George domain did
clash as from what he was told sakuna's
domain is a burialist domain here in
this bizarre statement everyone just
reacts shock unable to believe that his
domain doesn't even have a barrier as an
example of like just how impossible this
is kusakabe asks me what to toss him
that water however after she gives him
the bottle he throws it back telling her
to give him the water not the bottle
confused maybe we'll just facials the
absolute hell out of kuzakabe while and
behind him Mason explains they're
expanding their domain without a barrier
it's like trying to hold water without a
bottle with no container can you even
accumulate water can you paint on thin
air without a canvas with no stem roots
or leaves can a flower bloom from a seed
Maggie Compares it to using software
without even having a PC to run anything
on as frankly unfathomable in their eyes
it's completely impossible even still
she notes that Mickey Mouse domain was
neither enclosed within a barrier and
having heard that before Mega Millions
given his great promotion kusakave
explained that to use it he actually had
to use an existing structure to enclose
his domain Naruto shikemo or like as we
know him now good or kinshaku was able
to pull it off by himself so it does
prove that it can happen choso who
actually fought during that battle
pointed out that they're prepared to use
a simple domain on hinjaku while tinken
dismantled his domain from the outside
however because of the burialist domain
it was this simple domain that was torn
apart miwa who's confused over what
exactly would Clash in the slight attack
states that the short effect is imbued
within the barrier itself so it could
only clash with another barrier she also
realizes that well everyone's talking as
if their domains are a given but domains
devour an insane amount of curse energy
so wouldn't avoiding using them make
sense and yumaki speaks up and notes
that well it doesn't really matter since
Gojo has an infinite amount of curse
energy and your nose had that like fact
isn't actually true and it's just due to
how he's skilled at using his specific
technique if his cousin energy
consumption rape ends up being less than
what he actually replenishes then it
could technically run out that's just
working under the assumption though that
he's using it like normal if he changes
things up and starts using domains
executively then they could be
completely different story now I haven't
even mentioned what sakuna is actually
capable of as well in fighting kashimu
speaks up to state that the sharpness of
his techniques activation is
unparalleled the way you can switch
things up in a matter of milliseconds
from innate techniques to domain
amplifications is utterly amazing if
Gojo literally wasn't who he is then
zakuna would comfortably be winning in
terms of cursed energy utilization
what's more his total curse energy
output is probably even more than yota's
from what he can physically tell he'd
say it's probably double the amount that
he actually has Momo who's been pretty
quiet this entire chat speaks up and
feels that maybe nobody not even them
knows how this is going to play out if
Gojo and tsukunu's domains do Clash who
knows what could possibly happen then
right on that exact moment and after all
of this insane buildup that we just went
through hecarima signal that they are
about to begin the domain clashes back
in Shinjuku bosakuna and Gojo throw up
their respective hand signs to
simultaneously open the infinite void
and malevolent crying was a Kona now
appearing above his Shrine and Gojo
standing a few feet back it's explained
that the two are evenly matched they
form a perfect pair within Gojo's
barrier which in turn meant they're both
guaranteed hits overlapped each other
then canceled themselves owls in this
battle and as the two expand their
domains should either one of them
sustain severe damage it will cause the
collapse of their domain and the other
ones sure hats will immediately take
effect back at the TV room kuzukabe and
meimei both reacts in shock as somehow
even with their domains active they're
still evenly matched and Shinjuku the
pure force of the two overlapping
domains caused the surrounding area to
start getting atomized sadly for Gojo
the effective range of sukuna's domain
reaches even beyond their of a barrier
and just as Eugene knows that a domain
expansion is weak from the outside
goju's domain cracks and shatters as
it's showing that below it sukunu's
domain now sit perfectly fine with no
protection against the Kona short hit
technique the effect immediately flies
forth and seemingly cuts down the
strongest culture of today having taken
the slash to the neck Gojo nonchalantly
activates his reverse curse technique
watch everyone Becca the layer reacts to
hagaruma states that as long as Gojo
stays in range the slashes will never
stop coming chosu who assumes escaping
is probably the Port of Call for Gojo
has backed up by hakari who someone
agreed with him however it's more that
Hikari assumes Gojo will make a dash for
the exit whereas fusukabe realizes that
teleporting is out of the question since
it's an application of the Limitless
technique due to the use of his domain
expansion and it being destroyed it's
plausible that for a moment he can't use
his curse technique which like they
State means he's in store for one hell
of a beat down back inside of sakuna's
domain expansion Gojo is relentlessly
slashed over and over again by the short
head effect of the domain somehow though
Gojo manages to calm himself as he knows
for a fact that when it comes down to
techniques Limitless is far better
having been able to consistently
overpower sukuna's short head effect
with his use of reverse curse technique
Gojo just like what everyone else had
expected make a dash for the excerpt
sukuna immediately makes a dash to keep
up with him while remarking that he
isn't going to just let him Escape
grabbing his leg though Gojo still will
constantly getting slashed pulls him in
and nasikuna into the floor towering
over him got your potential and a curse
energy Infuse overhand but misses only
cracking the floor as sukuna manages to
quickly weasel his way out standing
there and looking at his opponent sukunu
remarks that Gojo's still moving pretty
well considering that he's been
activating his reverse curse technique
at full output in order to survive the
constant slashing goju on the other hand
notices something extremely important to
him it looks like malevolent Shrine
itself is the heart of the domain not
sakona back inside of the headquarters
Yuji Ponders what would happen if
someone did destroy the heart of the
domain or like the shrine specifically
the Big Bang kuzakabe brings up their
objects inside of domains don't tend to
hold any special meaning or significance
so think of it as like it wasn't even
there to begin with Mason thinks that if
it is a symbol of the domain then you
wouldn't even be able to destroy it and
even considering Gojo's insane skills it
doesn't look like he's taken any
measures to actually try to destroy it
suddenly Gojo activates the new Shadow
style simple domain taking kusakaya Bay
by surprise as he probably didn't expect
to see this one Yuji though noted that
Gojo said one time he could use it but
wasn't able to actually teach her during
the battle he was able to use the simple
domain to counter the short head effect
while simultaneously using reverse curse
technique to heal its body confused Yuji
wonders how one even manipulates their
own curse energy while reverse curse
technique is active again Gojo activates
another use of this simple domain before
darting at sakuna and attempted to
strike him in an instant he's once again
pounded by the short head effect
layering Gojo with a plethora of cuts
though again he activates another use of
simple domain and reverse curse
technique causing sakona to call us all
a little bit tedious right now randomly
though everyone back at the headquarters
is taken by surprise when they see Gojo
started attacking sakona once more
without using reverse picnic to heal
himself someone wonders if he's running
low on cursed energy but you to refutes
this as it's it's frankly impossible
there's no limit to go just curse energy
even though there totally is speaking up
though Eno mentions that like I said
before the Assumption rate could
currently be off right after domain
expansion he started using reverse curse
technique and maximum output which uses
up twice as much curse energy and that's
not even taken into account the fact
that sakuna is also rushing at Gojo
himself with the two powerhouses of this
series also rushing at each other once
again and he cuts not stopping for Gojo
everyone wonders if Gojo is about to
lose jumping on sukuna though and
rabbing his hands around the back of his
head Gojo activates his curse technique
reversal before leaning back and pulling
his hands up in preparation to end the
fights Blown Away with what he's just
witnessed he'd wonders if it's even
possible in his mind the reason he
wasn't able to heal himself for a moment
was because Gojo was using reverse
acoustic knee to heal his exhaust
acoustic technique unleashing red goju
shoots forth a blast of review technique
propelling sakuna back into the shrine
that makes up the center of his domain
noting that like he somehow managed to
survive the blast goju activates reverse
curse technique to heal and jokes that
damn this tutor's really turning into a
pain on the ass going into like more
depth on the insane feet Gojo just did
you do explains that acoustic neck which
has been burned out by using domain
expansion as an entirely different
matter than physical damage it's like
when a machine overheats if it isn't
broken you have to let it cool down or
it won't work again interpreting this
Maki makes it easier to understand by
saying that reverse curse technique can
repair damage but it can't help with the
cooling effects of Earth however it
looks as if this understanding of the
ability is completely wrong back in
Shinjuku and having made it out of the
effective range Gojo asks that sukuna is
able to expand the size of his area not
even giving Gojo a second to thank
sukuna until he expands the size of the
malevolent shrine's domain expansion to
its maximum in this same moment Gojo to
the shock of everyone also expanded his
his infinite void for a second time with
everyone watching they wonder if God is
really dumb enough to just fall into the
same Travis before May notices it first
though and hegaruma who by the way like
for a new sorcerer is so big brain state
that Goku switched conditions on the
external and internal conditions of his
barrier which and simple enough terms
for myself and Yuji to understand means
that Gojo this time is able to protect
himself against the attacks from outside
of his domain re-initiating the better
once more both Gojo and sukuna trade
hands back and forth but not once for
the hurts actually end up landing on
either side jumping back Gojo is
absolutely blown away as he understands
that somehow sukunu was able to use his
domain expansion and amplification at
the exact same time on top of that he's
becoming more comfortable inside of his
own infinite void and his curse energy
output is only increasing so and usual
Jiu Jitsu Kai is in combat you cannot
use nna technique that is etched into
your body while using a domain amp but
if you go in and view your domain well
they technique itself then this is an
entirely new situation throw any punch
tsukuna manages to dodge back out of the
way however as he pushes trying to
strike Dojo the six size Maniac manages
to evade the strike and thump the side
of sukunu's body managing to spin out of
Gojo's side he quickly understands that
somehow and while inside of his own
domain zakuna turned off his short head
effect knowing that the only ones who
are unaffected by infinite void are Gojo
and anyone he touches sukuna's plan is
to expand his effective range and
increase the power of The Binding vowel
even further than he did in Shibuya with
mega Me by using it by new vowel sukuna
is able to further increase the power of
His domain outside of Gojo's domain he
does that by removing his short hit
guarantee inside of the domain or
simultaneously also keeping himself safe
from infinite void by touching Gojo due
to all of this and again just like last
time Gojo's domain collapses and the man
is followed by plethora of strikes that
seemingly knock him away from sakona
with everyone back at like the TV
station he caught his place whatever it
honestly is I don't clue what to even
call it reacting horror to what's going
on in the current battle how do you most
stay instead of Gojo dies here he's
going out to fight next so don't even
try and stop him over in Shinjuku Gojo
activates another technique that he
notes he hasn't used much since he
mastered his domain seeing this kusakabe
spits out of smoke in awe of just having
the same Gojo use the falling Blossom
emotion for those of you who forgot
because I think it's only been used like
maybe two or three times throughout the
series it's a secret art of The Big
Three Families an anti-domain technique
all in all it's an application of curse
energy that automatically repels
anything you touch it wouldn't even be
able to do something against the complex
domain like infinite void but if you're
up against something like simple slashes
it's pretty useful jumping in Shoku says
that he most likely used it so he can
heal his burned out curse technique or
at the least buy some time again though
like what is this the third time now
Gojo blows them all away as he activates
another use of infinite void unlike all
of the previous uses though the time
it's completely massive in comparison
and akashimo's eyes it looks as if Gojo
was trying to encapsulate all of
sukuna's domain within his own barrier
May thinks that it's a bad move trying
to expand her domain to that size as
it'll drastically lower its
Effectiveness and like her guruma States
even if the domain isn't destroyed as
still pointless unless he wins the
battle inside of it suddenly Gojo's
domain cracks putting everyone on edge
and making them think that it's about to
fail Momo though quickly speaks up that
no it's not broken in fact the barrier
is quickly changing size and now it's
only a fraction of the original size
with Gojo's domain only like the size of
a basketball now because it can't be
remarked this is this is frankly
impossible because he made to joke about
how many times they've said these words
today Marky curiously questions its
outward appearance and if the inside is
dead of a similar size kusakabi agrees
with her as that's why when you're
usually trapped inside one you can't get
out unless you find the edge of the
barrier even if you find their Edge a
normal domain is resistant to attacks on
the outside so Escape is extremely
limited what's most important when it
comes to a barrier technique is a
concrete image usually if you try and
envision a barrier too small enough to
hold yourself and an opponent it would
just collapse just like the prison realm
though and probably due to his time
being confined in a small space there as
now allowing Gojo to take that and
implement it into his domain during the
battle still kuzakabe can't grasp the
process around how he's able to change
the conditions of his domain each time
he uses it barriers particularly domain
barriers typically have a set of
internal and external parameters by
discovering their own blend of these
parameters every sorcerer is able to
establish their own domain confused and
piping their heads up as obviously this
wasn't how Higa Roma and Hikari figured
out their domains like they open their
domains by default as a part of the
occurs technique in any case they aren't
usually things that can be changed
easily kuzuki Ponders if he changed the
size of his domain because it was too
difficult to maintain the larger surface
Mass so we had to compress it to make
things easier or maybe it was because he
wanted to see if he could cover all of
the middle Shrine with an even larger
barrier with goyo's domain beginning to
shake back and forth it's such a
tremendous speed the Earth itself begins
to rumble May points out that even still
Gojo's domain has managed to hold a new
to state that zakuna has also decreased
his domain so he could increase the
output of his curse technique so pretty
much now if this version of Gojo's
barrier does end up breaking they'll
enter a stalemate however Gojo will
actually end up being on the back foot
as he will run out of options technique
wise flashing back over to Shinjuku
sadly once more Gojo's domain is getting
shattered and tsukuna emerges Victorious
for a third time in the domain struggle
it's it's either the third or the fourth
now I'm honestly losing track throughout
the script here having watched his
Sensei reappear Yuji screams out for him
however in that moment all of the other
sorcerers are flabbergasted as they
witness the kona's malevolent Shrine
start to crumble and fall to pieces on
top of that it's shown that at some
point throughout the domain struggle
Gojo was able to lend a clean blow to
the chest of sakona causing in the king
of curses to finally take some proper
damage seeing this over their monitors
all of these Sorcerers screaming Joy
believing that goju still has a chance
to win in this battle funnily enough it
was actually simultaneous at the exact
same time zakuna destroyed Goku's domain
from the outside Gojo had actually
destroyed sakuna's domain to the point
that he wasn't able to maintain it any
longer yelling at me were kusakabe asks
if she was able to keep track of what's
going on in this fight or if anyone kept
track of the time that Gojo's barrier
was active speaking up Mei reveals that
it was active for three minutes and 9
seconds but if it was more specifically
after the moment that it was minimized
then that was exactly three minutes
hikarumo believes that now the domains
have collapsed neither of them will be
able to use the curse techniques anymore
if that is the case monkey thinks Gojo
can make the first move since he can
restore his burnt out curse technique
just like he did before but sadly sukuna
can also do the same with reverse curse
technique and speaking of himself now
that he knows how how it works you know
theorizes that he could probably do it
too though like he mentioned earlier it
can't be used to heal a burnt out curse
technique but it actually can he's just
like he's just tripping right now the
reasoning that Gojo actually showing
this to sukuna is a terrible problem for
everyone is because back in the past
zakuna was able to split his Spirit 20
times into 20 different objects called
zacona's cursed fingers after seeing
this ability just once in the past
sakuna learned how to turn himself into
a cursed object and now that he's seen
this new ability it's most likely he'll
also be able to restore his burnt out
curse technique and Shinjuku so couldn't
boost his way up onto a bridge giving a
moment of pace before noticing that
random parts of the road start to get
smashed up from below quickly jumping
off the bridge and onto some railing
nearby secunda notices Gojo break his
way up through the bricks behind him
then turning back around realizes that
his Escape rope was blocked by a ball of
rocks that Gojo had perfectly floated
there using his Infinity with absolutely
nowhere to go saguna throws up his hands
to block and takes a kick that seems
sliding back along the side wall taking
a moment to think about the fight got
your wonders why sakuna has been
stubbornly avoiding using any other
curse technique than his own even when
the strength of the barrier was lowered
and Gojo had flipped the conditions on
it he didn't try to destroy it from the
inside instead he took the riskier
option while they canceled out each
other's short head effects from within
the domain squid had no other choice but
to use his domain amplification in order
to beat his Limitless curse technique
which was actually a massive Advantage
for our man still as he saw earlier
within a domain sukune is unable to use
buildings to attack in fact until after
kojo's domain was destroyed he
technically had the upper hand for over
three minutes yet in spite of that he
can't seem to understand why sukuna
didn't ever attempt to make use of
something from the 10 Shadows technique
or maharaga while in a domain he has the
memory of Mega me and the conversation
that happened between them so he knows
for a fact that someone of the exact
same power died to a person like Mega me
goju just Ponders if he's scared he'll
beat maharaga in one shot however in
that exact same moment the wheel turns
and blood begins to drip from his own
nose [__] nosebleed though God you
was baiting out damn ass with that one
and in an instant both him and sakona
throw up their hands and reform another
domain Clash yuju points out that again
they activated it at the exact same time
an angel who's right next to him brings
up there's a Kona can now restore his
burnt out curse technique or maybe just
decided to hide the fact that he could
until now because Abby knows that within
the next three minutes that actually
takes a Kona to destroy Gojo's domain
from the outside Gojo will need to
damage the Kona City point he can't
maintain his domain from the inside
shoko joking that they probably
shouldn't talk as if Gojo was only back
foot yet brings up that if sakuna is hit
At All by unlimited void then man is
completely done for due to this it's
Susan that if Gojo was able to destroy
the malevolent Shrine within the next
three minutes then he will win this
battle inside of Shinjuku and having
fled up his curse energy fists goju
pounds sukuna with a barrage of punches
that really only bruises the king of
Kirsten's arms jumping up sakuna tries
to quickly get over his Shrine however
he's knocked into the floor then while
incapacitated is grabbed by Gojo's
infinity and pulled towards himself
having been flung towards Gojo zagona
just manages to block a devastating
stomach punch randomly though and I'm
assuming man's used like yuji's
Divergent punch to delay the like hit of
his cursed energy sukunism malevolent
Shrine is completely destroyed while in
the exact same moment Gojo's domain also
ends falling to the ground and looking
up as evident that this time sukuna took
a serious blow as half of his face
appears to be missing with everyone
believing that when it comes down to
domain struggles goja was Stronger they
all hope deeper than themselves that he
can when beckon the battle and throwing
a fat right hook Goku scenes to kuna
straight back into the side of a bridge
pillar breaking it in the process I
don't know I don't even know what we're
at now like this is utterly insane and
in that moment Gojo and sakuna launch
another set of domain struggles yet
unlike all of the previous battles
something is actually different here for
the first time and Utah can't help but
feel like maybe just maybe Gojo was able
to expand his domain earlier inside of
the domain struggle it is revealed that
zakuna was indeed busy healing his body
and because of that it was late
restoring his curse technique it was
less than 0.01 seconds but unlimited
void landed on him as an infinite set of
infinite information rushes into the
cerebral cortex of History's Strongest
Sorcerer And the king of curses El man
today's current demon rushes forth and
pierces the chest of Darkness incarnate
only 2 minutes and 40 seconds after they
expanded their domains Gojo was able to
collapse malevolent Shrine within his
innate compound with nothing not even
the friction in the ear available for
zaconus to use now he stands there
dumbfounded as the full effects of
saturno Gojo's infinite Foy connects
with its brain not done yet himself Gojo
lets everyone know that crushing his
heart was only the beginning now he's
gonna take everything from him however
before he's able to even connect with
sakona a set of prolific words are
spoken with this treasure I summon
eight-handled sword Divergent sylla
Divine General maharaga Skitty now with
the fact that like sukuna managed to
summon him in that moment because who
just assumes that it hasn't had time to
adapt to unlimited void yet so surely he
can destroyed and one short activating
curse technique reversal Gojo is just
baffled when he Witnesses maharaga
literally not Kia and instead with this
sort of extermination slashes down
completely destroying Gojo's infinite
void falling to the ground now Gojo can
only gasp as he realizes that somehow
Maharaja had already adapted to his
domain expansion allowing him to freely
attack from the inside realizing that
maharaga had been summoned Jose points
out that it has the ability to adapt to
any attack even unlimited void using
reverse curse technique and with
maharaga by his side secunda knows that
Gojo was well aware of the sugargami's
abilities any battles so far both of you
guys have had the domains cancel each
other's out a total of five times go to
short head effect targeted everything
within their domain whereas succonus
your head effect targeted everything
inside the domain with the exception of
himself this means that this short had
effect targeting sukuna was still in
place crazily enough one of the duo was
able to take on unlimited void a total
of five times we'll walk shouldering the
burden of maharaga's adaption this
person wasn't sukuna though no it was
someone else entirely blowing away with
the Revelation Gojo quickly figures that
somehow he managed to adapt to unlimited
void within 0.01 seconds of his domain
opening doing some more crazy deductions
he figures that like I said somehow
sukuna overcame the burden of maharaja's
adaption ability then realizing he's
wrong states that the one actually taken
the damage was migami's Soul deep inside
the conscious of migami's mind we see
him barely awake with maharaga's wheel
floating directly above him seeing Gojo
now and wondering what's on his mind
sukuna asks what's up to which God just
says nothing really it just warms his
heart to see him using such fraudulent
abilities replying to his
underhandedness scooter states that
unlimited void is an ability that Gojo
activated once inside of his domain he
originally expected it to be a pain in
the ass trying to figure out this
technique and at the start of the fight
he had planned to neutralize it first so
while unable to use amplification within
the domain sukunu used migami salt to
adapt to unlimited void using his own
tin Shadows technique as a result he
wasn't able to use anything other than
what was originally imbued into his own
domain knowing that origami took then
was the process of adaption not led the
full effect of infinite void itself goju
begins pulling up his hand and remarking
that tsukuna hasn't actually adapted
Mega me soul itself to unlimited void
and if he opens his domain once more
he'll destroy him in one attack not
phased over this though sukuna kinda
just laughs and taunts Gojo while
telling him that he's no longer able to
open his domain instantly and as he
tries activating it once more but I'd
begin streaming from his nose and
everyone back at headquarters still
watching new monitors begins freaking
out over the possible outcomes by the
way who do you guys think has left from
the headquarters like we can see a few
people are still there from like
flashing around between now and like
what's released I have a few thoughts in
my life will I where's takaba I haven't
seen him since the uh the start of their
conversation I'm pretty sure back at
like 220 something anyway anyway get
back to the story having found a way in
now securing remarks that using reverse
curse technique to heal is exhausted
innate technique looks to restrain his
physical brain quite a bit to him it's
evident that his brain more specifically
the prefrontal cortex for the
information on curse techniques is
located has been destroyed and repaired
far too many times using reverse curse
technique to heal his burnt out curse
technique now oh my God man the amount
of times I have said curse technique
reverse curse technique throughout this
video like I am so confused and I've
probably messed it up like once or twice
I I probably have anyway anyway
terrified at the fact that Gojo had been
using such a wild technique you usually
just screams that this is way too risky
they all know that the brain especially
that section of the brain is the most
important and you can't even compare it
to Simply repairing someone's normal
bodily damage Shoku speaks up nervous
over the fact that she kind of assumed
by now that Gojo had gotten used to this
effect on his brain however it looks
like he's beginning to suffer on top of
that second has actually done it fewer
times so he's in a much healthier better
condition back in Shinjuku and as Gojo
drops to one knee Schooner states that
Gojo has reached his limits even if he
could have expanded his domain again he
would have lost the instant that he did
not to mention the fact that he wouldn't
even be able to make it precise enough
to actually be a threat to sukona
taunting him like the demon he truly is
secular lets Gojo no then next up he'll
bring the circumference of his domain
and woods from there he'll be left with
nowhere to run and as he carves him up
he'll simultaneously adapt to his
Infinity say in his final goodbyes he
states that Gojo was born into an era
without sukuna and was hailed as the
strongest of that era yet and the end he
just turned out to be plainfully
ordinary saying those prolific words
domain expansion One Last Time sakuna
proceeds to unleash his domain however
in that exact moment all of his eyes
began bleeding profusely and the domain
fails so crazily enough from the time of
the previous domains this last
conversation had happened in 10 seconds
and yet just like Gojo sukuna's brain
had sustained enough damage to now make
an expansion impossible jumping up and
laughing at sukuna after saying this
gotcha just noticed it it looks like
it's hitting him pretty hard now then
pointing at maze crows he knows that all
of his students are watching him put his
life on the line so he's gonna go ahead
and keep showing off for them jumping
forth with a speed that sukuna is unable
to keep up with Gojo throws a fat right
hook to let his opponent know that he
still has a long way to go to defeat him
over inside of the main group's Hideout
kuzukabe asks who there had been
seriously punched by Gojo before a few
people speak up noticing there well he
didn't hit them but they tried their
best to punch him as hard as they could
and it was physically impossible due to
only like a few people taking a hit
though kusakabe who I'm assuming has as
well says that his fists are enhanced
with curse energy and only moments of
impact blue repeatedly absorbs the
surrounding space that feels as if
you're being counter-attacked after
preparing for a regular blow Herrera
wonders if it heard and Hikari along
with you to both reveal that they puked
after the head they took the Naomi once
told Yuji that if he planned on
continuing as a sorcerer then he
shouldn't compare himself to Gojo he
stated that he put a massive deal of
effort behind his critical hurts but
Gojo could casually perform them as if
it was an everyday thing putting them
all back on track though and what
kuzakabe was mainly trying to explain
was that from here on out when it comes
to straight hands he doesn't have a clue
what Gojo was doing back in Shinjuku at
Sean that Gojo is completely dominating
sukuna in a physical fight he boosts any
building was smashing zakuna until every
level before turning around and tossing
them over the road when zakuna lands
Gojo uses all of the rubble that had
previously broken away from their
building to entrap the king of curses
and started break coffin exploding out
of the reinforced brick scooter darts
forth and quickly dust a head kick from
Gojo hitting core under his trap though
Gojo slams his leg down only the sea
sakona flip out of the way and prepare
his own X Kirk all of a sudden he stops
though as he sees what seems like Gojo
running at such a high speed it's begun
creating a circle of after images
thinking that he has the upper hand now
go through darts and a strike but sukuna
manages to spot the real image and grab
his hand before following up and
punching him straight in the face being
sent backwards Gojo clearly regains his
orientation and lets he top and nearby
street lights walking towards him sukuna
explains that furu's Incarnation used to
like manifest maharaga along with a
wheel represents complete circulation
and Harmony once maharaga has been
attacked the wheel turns and the
adaption begins with that said the Will
turns and maharaga seemingly adapts got
your nose that winter Cooney uses domain
amplification and touches him the wheel
turns black so it's safe to assume then
in his eyes that it interrupts the
adaption process as tsukuna can't
activate his domain but can use
amplification that's probably because
the area of his brain originally damaged
was in charge of barrier techniques over
the sakona now as he slowly strolls
forth he thinks that Gojo is most likely
only using laps to avoid having his
other techniques adapted which makes
perfect sense in his eyes as the lights
think go green the two of them rushes
each other once more clashing in the
middle of the road with a light Gojo was
just on falling behind sakuna he quickly
grabs it and Buffs it towards Gojo
however it freezes as the object
connects with his Infinity they go for
the main group now as they all note that
its random maharaga hasn't reappeared
they suppose that it had already adapted
once unlimited void was used for a fifth
time taken like their knowledge in carry
the doses that maybe the wheel has to
turn a few times in order for zacona to
adapt to Gojo's limit technique then
just like they assume and asukuna asked
if Gojo had been paying attention to his
ability Alman explains that he needs
four spins in total which technically
means only three more spins of the wheel
and to maharaga fully adapt to kojo's
Infinity walking towards each other
again sakuna jokes that they now have a
countdown to win Gojo's idiotic smirk
will be wiped from his face who's now go
to smile right back and tell him the
same damn thing in fact Gojo takes it
one step further saying that he'll beat
him dead before he even makes it to the
third spin still eagerly watching the
battle Hannah questions if God was just
forgotten about Mega me to watch Yuji
says that man might really have hearing
them and looking ready to throw some
hands himself kashimo jokes that it's
fine let him forget megaming leading to
fikit Mickey Mika's uh man's in a
slightly tight spot right now Yuji
watches as maharaga's wheel spins for
the second time meaning that is only two
more spins until Gojo's Infinity will be
fully adapted too turning his hands into
perfectly constructed orbs of glucose
energy Gojo flings amitsukona making him
acrobatically flip out of the way as the
ability burns the bridge from existence
capturing sukuna within his range Gojo
sticks both of his hands forth and
creates more cursed energy orbs that
Circle his Target leaving him with
nowhere to escape somehow escaping
though sakuna manages to dug down before
darting off causing all of the orbs to
immediately change direction and start
tracking his new position boasting it
around one of the nearby pillars goju
flies up and quickly blocks akuna's Kirk
having gained the advantage now he
follows up by kicking his opponent down
towards the road below while falling the
wheel spins for the third time making
everyone back at the TV room get more
and more nervous over the impending
adaption Yuji curiously wonders if it's
time that's needed for the wheel to
adapt or if it was Battle experience
realizing what Yuji was trying to say
kusakave solidifies his question by also
pondering if a does it take one attack
think time for the wheel to understand
then adapt or B as it adapting after
taking multiple blows still not even
sure himself he points out that hasn't
used anything other than Labs so he
doesn't even know and compounding that
kashimo states that either option is
actually possible that's the reality of
the situation following the king of
curses through one of the nearby
buildings Windows got your remarks that
from now on he's going to give him hell
in his eyes he's convinced sakuna that
all he's using is blue so with this
timing he won't be able to react pulling
up his hand and firing a point-blank
shot of curse technique reversal red
Gojo just watches as the wheel turns
black signifying that sakona had
activated his domain amplification as
the technique hits and because of what I
previously just mentioned zakuna was
just barely able to minimize the damage
in time activating his reverse curse
technique to heal sukuna thinks that he
expected this even Earth amplification
can neutralize the low output of
Limitless it can't fully cancel out blue
or the Reversed reared Yuji and kusukabe
both react in abject horror as they
realize that at this rate zakuna will
fully adapt his technique looking
heavily beaten and bruised secunda turns
around to Vermont that Gojo is sloppy
and questions are the greatest Sorcerer
of today had lost his call once his hand
was read randomly though Goji doesn't
attack and instead he just tells his
opponent that you know like the ready
shot back before well it hasn't actually
exploded yet suddenly taking one of the
hardest back shots in the figure of
world that is Jiu Jitsu Kaizen sukuna
gasps in pain as he realizes that hey
the king of curses was taken from behind
quickly calculating the building's
layout he figures that Gojo must have
planned from the start to have red
strike after one full lap not giving him
a chance to recover Gojo follows up and
pounds to kuna so damn hard with a black
flash that physically knocks Akuna out
for a moment everyone back at the TV
room just watches an ore as they never
expected such an ability to land let
alone be as successful as it was back in
Shinjuku blood pours from sakuna's mouth
and the wheel Falls symbolizing the
defeat of History stronger sorcerer
randomly though the wheel picks up speed
and Spins for the final time while at
the exact same time a stun JoJo falls
into a pool of darkness and maharaga's
demonic hands reach out for him with
nowhere to go maharaga grabs Gojo and
slices his chest with the sword of
extermination leaving everyone's hope of
survival on the brink of death
beads of sweat drip from everyone's head
as they worry about how things could
have taken a turn for the worse with
Gojo since maharaga like has arrived now
it means that he's completely adapted to
Gojo's technique Yuji however stays
hopeful as in his eyes maharaga only
adapted to the infinity which means it's
only an equal fight now and Gojo can
heal up right away using reverse curse
technique standing nearby and looking
absolutely stressed shoko explains that
she's been smoking a ton during this
battle sadly she thinks it isn't just a
case of healing up a game instead it's
more that Gojo's healing is gradually
becoming slower than usual it was
extended use of red if the already
prolonged Fight Continues and might end
up with him not being able to use his
curse technique reversal to heal as
quickly therefore he could actually lose
though she does pose that that situation
is probably the exact same for sakona
Gojo's opponent is the king of curses
initially when the battle kicked off
everyone thought that it would be
impossible for Gojo to win and now with
what they've seen that thought is slowly
creeping back in even Gojo himself has
begun thinking the same thing wondering
how long it's been since he felt like
this it reminds him of a battle 11 years
earlier against toji fushiguro and how
now he's beginning to feel the same
satisfaction from fighting that's
pushing him to an even higher degree
throughout the special being the
strongest sadly comes with the title of
also being the loneliest and now the
only thing that will truly satisfy him
flying forth God your head to maharago
with a direct hit that pushes the god
chickagami back instantly following up
he tries to activate red in order to
finish him off but sakuna jumps back in
and uses megami's rabbit escape to cover
maharaga and allow him to prepare for
the next attack having watched his
opponent try his best to obey every
attack Gojo moksukuna asking him how
long is going to rest for after taking
the black flash and that it was pretty
obvious it's a fix are still hurting him
suddenly sukuna mixes things up and
throws a fire extinguisher to cover
himself and make an opening for maharaga
to attack Gojo as Gojo was caught up in
his fight with biggie zakuna uses a new
application of migami's Max elephant
chikagami to shoot a blast of water that
mirrors choso's piercing blood technique
just as Gojo defends himself against
maharaga sakuru's attack lands and
wounds his arm flying backwards Gojo
realizes that tsukuna is mainly waiting
for his Infinity ability to vanish
meaning that the fight would eventually
turn into a pure 2V1 if it continues
annoyed he wonders how sakuna is even
able to use the abilities of the
tsukigami without summoning them in the
first place like migami has to go
through this whole procedure where a
sakuna can wear the wheel and summon the
sugargami with what I'm assuming are
just his thoughts here Gojo knows that
sensokuna was able to adapt to his
Infinity ability he's going to have to
use more curse energy that's why he's
been simultaneously using the shukigami
however he does explain that asakuna
wants to adapt to red and will take much
longer to do so katina's brainstorming
off though sakuna beams his way back
into the picture while stating that this
isn't a 1v2 numpty I'm the fraudulent
one moving his hands together Sakura
summons a brand new got me cold they
come here a based agito making this
previously 2V1 a now 3v1 battle and
putting Gojo even further onto the back
foot according to take what I've seen
online and everything since the chapter
drop Chimera base is a mixture of new
way and totality which is probably a
combination that I never actually saw
coming and leaves so many other weird
and wacky hybrids of creation of the
future but obviously you know moving
forward goes your own self even jokes
that with those two Giants standing
there sakuna looks like a lost child and
a flash the two beasts had the fight
once more with Gojo just barely being
able to dodge the initial attacks
randomly and stealing some more of
megami's techniques sakuna pops out of
Gojo Shadows with his hands aimed like a
pistol and shoot another water blast
like piercing blood from Max elephant's
ability but Gojo Dodges there too so I'm
in his fists down Gojo just misses
asukuna backflips out of the way
allowing his boys to follow up with a
dual hook from either side somehow
dodging each of these large creatures
and arriving behind maharaga Gojo
proceeds to blast him with red but his
Bill even effective enough to burn the
creature now figuring that man's
probably stuffed if he doesn't do
something completely insane here Goji
deduces there he has to use this damn
technique in order to be able to finish
off maharaga in one shot at a mess of
risk is zakuna will most likely notice
the race output but it's a risk he's
willing to take with a glimmer of hope
and a cheeky grin on his face Gojo's
face that he's got no other choice it's
time to use the unlimited Hollow
technique
gripping his blade tightly oh my what
did I why did I start like anyway you
just speaks up and tells the group that
he's going to join the battle to help
Gojo not pleased to hear this as he
stated that he was going to be the first
to leave kashimo Sparks up his cursed
energy and warns Yuta to not interfere
as it's him who will go and fight next
seeing his boy's cursed energy flare up
hakari asks you to to calm down and says
Gojo had initially asked him to tag in
when he starts to lose the battle or
gets overwhelmed but yulu rebukes her
saying that since okuna's domain
expansion is now disabled he can help
Gojo out by handling natosha kagamis
with Riker speaking up Mucky tells
kashimoto to not forget his overall role
in the special if he's defeated then
some of the backup insurance will be
gone you know it's just like but bruh if
we go for it now and take this Gamble
and win against sakuna then the
insurance won't be needed at all
probably just eager to test this new
body swapping ability Yuji takes you to
side and encourages him to go for it I
love her like this backup plan of theirs
really hasn't even been discussed at all
we kind of skipped over that month as
I've been over in the past fast like we
know for a fact kashimot city is going
to be the next enter but we have no idea
when that's actually going to be at this
point but was this even spoken about
beforehand with Gojo Yuda kind of made
it seem like they've all had this chat
in the days before this battle so I'm
assuming there is an underlying plan
that our team does have not just going
into this not having any plan at all but
anyways anyways they'll think that
because sakuna isn't able to give us
everything and Gojo is at his best when
he doesn't need to worry about others
the setup they currently earn has the
highest probability of winning getting
slightly bummed out with this both Yuji
and you to sulk after realizing that
they're probably just going to be a
hindrance if they enter pulling them
back to reality though kashimo tells
them that that's not exactly true at the
end of the day this is Gojo's fight and
it would just be lame as hell if they
all interfered Carrie himself suspects
that sakuna might actually have a trump
card and is preserving it for later so
if the sorcerers do act too quickly and
reveal their hand so kuna might end up
using that trap card on them skipping
away from our guys though and back
inside of Shinjuku the two Massive
shikigami Attack Gojo in a combination
attack however Gojo evades the attacks
with ease and lands his own
counter-attack black flash jumping back
it's shown that a guitar wasn't even
phased by the hurt and instead sends its
tail to attack which is in fact a
miniature version of the Great Serpent
proving that this base was probably made
up of even more sugargami than
originally thought ripping off the head
of the serpent tail got your watches as
maharaga quickly pushes the other
shikakami aside to protect it as it
heals pondering on this new base and
more Gojo thinks that agito is most
likely made up of nue which firstly
inherited the Great Serpent then the
mourn tiger and round deer still none of
that even matters in the larger scheme
of things since agito hasn't adapted to
Limitless like maharaga has got your
plans to destroy it in one short
stepping away for like what the second
time now another random reveal that I
almost completely missed the first time
around but what even is this mourn tiger
surely that's the 10th shikagami from
the 10 Shadows technique that we haven't
actually seen yet the lines across
agito's chest could resemble the Tiger's
markings I initially thought it was
something to do with sakona love to know
like what you guys all think and if
we'll ever actually get an explanation
on the shikagami in the future placing
his blade on the floor maharaga flicks
it at Gojo causing a line of rubble to
get thrown up into his face locking the
rocks with his Infinity Gojo then
proceeds to dodge out of the way of the
shikigami's follow-up attack continuing
dead then launches a fat head kick that
pushes the creature back turning around
goldra quickly activates his infinity
and brings his second shakigami in
closer having seen agito use RCT to heal
its tail before godger realizes that
it'll be Troublesome if it also heals
sakona during the battle so his plan is
to firstly deal with Earth elsewhere
inside of his dank shadowy wield saguna
starts creating a plan to not let Gojo
use his prolific Hollow purple he knows
that the last time Gojo used her the
attack was amped up to 120 percent still
he was able to take it head-on with
somewhat minimal damage since it was
coming from such a large distance
however due to everything that happened
since then if Dad does hit him with even
a 100 Hollow purple right now then it
will be fatal knowing that maharago
wasn't showing him everything sakuna
speaks up and asks his shikagami how
long it's going to make him wait he's
not dumb and knows it's no longer making
me shadow so demands that it shows him
what it's got following those orders
maharaga's wheel spins and sends forth
an ability that looks exactly like
sukuna's dismantle which slices the
greatest Sorcerer of today's arm right
off not leaving his shadowy realm sakuna
Chuckles and Praises Maharaja for its
Adept use of his technique while
simultaneously a bunch of the sorcerers
all scream in pure panic shoko
personally knows that this isn't great
timing at all as Gojo's healing is
currently weakened re-emerging from his
shadows and taking the advantage sekulu
punches Gojo before quickly following up
with a wicked snap kick that since God
you're directly into the path of a gator
who'd begun flaring up its own cursed
energy a geekso then proceeds to
absolutely Pummel Gojo's head with a fat
right Hawk however
a hole into the surface of Mars Gojo
looking completely manic looks into its
eyes while creating an orb of condensed
blue and tells a gito that for a while
now it wasn't worthy enough to be
considered an opponent in this battle
smashing his left hand down now Gojo
effortlessly thrashes around the
pathetic curse looking at sakona and
maharaga he submits arguto's uselessness
as he catches it completely within his
new blue maximum output and seems a
pathetic creature hurling towards the
Kona and maharaga dodging out of the way
of the blast zakuna can only watch as
the amalgamation of shikagamis is seen
hurling through Shinjuku before it is
eventually crushed and destroyed under
the pure force of Gojo's maximum output
technique 41 seconds later Gojo's purple
has also wrapped its way through the
battlefield in Shinjuku
gods and
the envious because become mortal
to any moment might be our last
everything's more beautiful
because we're doing in history there can
only ever be won the moniker of the
strongest is something passed down from
Titan to Titan something only a very
talented and blessed individual is
capable of achieving hard work and
determination means nothing at the basis
of how you build your strength is shaky
to begin with luckily for saturu Gojo
his infinite potential is built upon a
ground far stronger than that of a
stolen child's corpse having completely
annihilated agito who he didn't see is
fit to belong in his prisons it is said
that with Gojo having also landed a
second black flash his intensity
increased and as he felt a rush of
exhilaration flow through him he
activated his reverse curse technique
allowing him to comfortably heal that
previously failed arm on the other hand
and for the first time in 1 000 years
the king of curses ryoming sakuna
finally begins to feel the weight of
battle reignite in the fight godro stuns
everyone as he lands his third black
flash but this time on maharaga dating
back hitting takes Akuna by surprise as
he appears directly in front of him
saguna tries to throw a fat right hook
but Gojo comfortably Dodges it and grabs
the king of hers's hand before adjusting
his polarity and throwing him into mummy
maharaka not giving him a moment to
relax as well Gojo follows up with his
fourth black flash luckily for sakona
maharaga was able to block the strike
with the sword of extermination still
the impact from Gojo's punch smashed the
wall behind him and sent them sliding
back through one floor of an office
building floating outside that seat
office building Gojo raises his hand and
begins chanting in preparation for his
next technique phase preparation pillars
of light and Jujutsu a spark is the
curse energy that swells up inside a
sorcerer just before they go and
activate a technique and the moments
before a domain activation short hit
technique and other powerful abilities
there will be without exception a spark
even the great Gojo with his immense
curse energy isn't an exception to this
rule this fact doesn't change instead
it's all the more obvious for his hollow
technique purple and side of the
building and based on the incantations
that were said by Gojo along with the
scale of curse energy pot into those set
incantations tsukuna believes that they
spark currently before his eyes was that
of the curse technique reversal red so
what's a kona's plans are in preparation
for the attack as to have maharaga
Tankard then on top of that adapt to Red
to put Gojo in his place however
sukuna's judgment on this next attack
was by no means incorrect activating
curse technique reversal read Gojo
blasts his ability straight upwards into
the sky completely confusing sukuna as
he obviously thought he was going to
shoot it at him after a second thought
though he quickly comes to realize the
magnitude of what's happening and calls
forth maharaga blasting up through the
levels of the building maharaga shatters
each window as his speed of his movement
increases in an attempt to catch Gojo's
red moments after red was fired sakuna
figured thereby merging the lapse of
blue and the reversal of red Hollow
technique purple is formed producing an
imaginary mass that rushes forth
shooting itself outside of the building
now as shown that just ahead of maharaga
the red Gojo had previously fired was
headed directly at the perpetuated
technique that had crushed the gator
earlier blue in a general sense the
technique red falls into a standstill
before it will explode sakuna was able
to figure this out because of the
ability Gojo used on him last time you
know when he gave him the fat back shot
maharago was sent up by him to prevent
the abilities from merging firstly
what's a cone had planned for the
shikigami to do was to attack blue and
completely erase it as it like had
already adapted to Blue beforehand all
that ran through the beast's mind as it
tried to do this was a yearning to
fulfill orders traveling up at a rapid
speed though and using the attractive
force of his own blue satsuru Gojo flung
himself between his blue and maharaga
blue chooses its targets without bias
and because its attraction is an effect
in the adapted maharaga as a side effect
it causes adaption to actually backfire
lunging fourth goju lands a fat uppercut
on the shikigami that leaves sukuna with
no one to defend him as he prepares his
own last-ditch attack pulling up his
hands to perform another goose of his
piercing blood like ability shukuna
plans to disrupt emerging by causing the
explosion of breed first before it can
merge shooting off his ability Gojo
quickly follows up and punches the king
of curses in his side looking up and
seeing that as a belief who was able to
shoot forth and that it was about to
clash with gojos sakuna confidently
remarked that he was too slow unfazed by
this all Gojo quickly rattles off the
Incarnation for blue FaZe Twilight eyes
of plunger and such a short period of
time that an utterly stunned sakuna
glancing at his attack again he watches
as it passes into Gojo's steadily
merging technique not affecting it and
the slight Hurst the reason that it
didn't actually disrupt red right there
is because gochu in those last like
milliseconds before the uh technique was
about to hurt reactivated and restored
his outpod following the incarnations
that he just previously said which is
actually insane when you think about it
like I don't even know how man did that
anyway floating there with both foes on
each side of him Gojo starts his
incantations for the legendary Hollow
technique purple nine ropes polarized
light Crow and shomio the gap between
within and without what is in the battle
of the century back at the TV room Yuda
apologizes to kusakabe for what he had
said previously as to him it's pretty
obvious that if a burden touches himself
entered the battle then Gojo wouldn't
have been able to do this with both
colors fully combining and the purple
light of the Gods themselves getting
ever brighter Gojo looks upon both of
his terrified opponents faces and
finishes the incantation purple
instantly following the implosion of the
two techniques an imaginary force of
Unstoppable curse energy exploded
outwards destroying maharaga along with
anything and its path and completely
bury in all of Shinjuku under a carpeted
layer of rebar and Rubble Barefoot and
barely able to stand now sukuna having
survived the blast holds himself up
against a broken wall and front of him
Gojo states that well this was an
unlimited purple not bound by any
specific Target so it even damaged him
however as we kiss see it's obvious that
there's a difference in a level of their
damage Gojo assumes that it's just
because his curse energy pull is just
that large so in the end all's well that
ends well in his eyes he even jokes that
he totally crushed the Kona in the
improvisation Department with that use
of remote purple and that is the first
time his ever had to actually blow
himself up and then repair himself which
again is mental like how how do you even
do that I know like you can already see
but as long as you keep that part of the
brain there so I'm I'm imagining right
now God you blew his entire body up
apart from that one section of the brain
and it completely rehealed his body I
don't know man that's actually insane
when you think about it if you're
confused like icon of am right here and
how in the world Goji was able to start
using curse energy again well it's like
kusakave says here and how we all
learned earlier on back in the series
when our boy Yuji landed four of them
Gojo was able to regain his reverse
curse technique because of his use of
black flashes so you know like miracles
happen when people start Landing these
black flashes pretty much much you know
they they reach their true potential and
stuff so now what's the Kona hope has
slowed healing no maharaga and an
inability to do any more damage
it means that for sure 100 Gojo wins the
battle of the strongest Sorcerer And the
history of the Jiu Jitsu Kaizen universe
suddenly it all goes dark
ing through the unsettling quiet get all
yours out to a familiar someone saying
yo looking up with like a stupefied look
on his face Gojo groans confused with
his current predicament leaning back in
his chair goju tells his man that this
is probably the worst he could have got
hearing this ghetto moans obviously not
happy with his best mates initial
reaction to seeing him again before
telling him that he's been a bit rude
kind of annoyed gaju says he told his
students that when you die that's it you
are alone so he hopes this is all just a
part of his current imagination I'm
concerned even if it is ghetto asks why
it even matters to him but God replies
that it does matter because of because
of his father however he also realizes
that things are all set up for Shoku to
handle either way so it's actually okay
curious on what the battle was like you
know asked how strong the king of curses
was remembering the tough Fort battle
Gojo answers that sukuna was damn strong
and it didn't even go all out for the
win and effect he's not even sure he
could have won even if sakuna didn't
have migami's curse technique meaning
that even without maharaga zakuna would
have somehow won Blown Away with this
information ghetto was surprised that
sukuna made Gojo of all people had met
that he was truly weaker and feels sorry
for him Gojo says that he used to think
that him more than anyone else would be
able to empathize with sukuna about the
loneliness of being the strongest
however he still loved everyone and
wasn't ever truly feeling loneliness
somewhere along the way though a line
was drawn between himself and other
people or rather living beings he notes
that you can grow and love flowers over
time but what he rather wanted from it
was for those flowers to understand him
not gonna lie that's actually one
beautiful analogy for Gojo wanting all
of the young ones that he's teaching to
see him and how he does it so they can
learn themselves then grow from it
anyways anyways clutchina's first in
desperation God just says that he gave
us everything to try and win his train
body the techniques he learned
throughout life the talent he brushed
upon others inspiration and unparalleled
explosive Powers he says he wanted all
of him to reach the Kona and hopes that
he somewhat left an impact on the king
of curses absolute strength the
loneliness that comes from it Gojo
believes that truly someday someone will
teach him to love calms down now and
with a bit of a grin on his face he just
states that in the end the better was
fun for him though he just mainly feels
sorry for sakona because he wasn't able
to feel the same feeling and give his
all to Gojo looking at his best mate now
suguru says that Harry all of this made
him feel slightly jealous but if Gojo is
truly satisfied with her then he's also
on the same page as um satisfaction with
only one thing missing in his eyes goju
told him that he would have loved if
Guido was also there to give him a slap
on the back and motivate him along with
everyone else before battle maybe then
he could have truly been satisfied in
the end either away and pushing their
thought aside he stays there he's glad
what killed him in the end wasn't time
or disease but someone's stronger than
him grossed out with that level of
strength though anami perks up and asks
Gojo which Samurai General he currently
is says him on the airport chair behind
him then Army continues there what goja
was just saying is something that no one
in the Modern Age would ever say and
guesses that it's also why he was able
to live longer than him in the end
speaking up and making his short
re-entrance into the story as well you
hire virus says that the timing was just
a tad different for the big man in an
army obviously referring to their deaths
and stuff so like nanami died in Shibu
yeah and then only a couple months later
God he was passed away so he's saying
their timing wasn't too different
anyways anyways while telling Gojo to
stop roughing up his hair in an army my
dad says he once talked with ghetto
about leaving all of the work at jujuts
who take to Gojo in the end though he
returned because he knew Gojo didn't
consider Jujutsu as something to live
for or to protect rather he knew that
Gojo was mentally perverted and only use
sorcery to satisfy himself High bar are
looking happy as always adds that it's
something everyone noticed but didn't
exactly have the courage to say out loud
curiously as obviously we don't even
know what happened an army says he won't
justify Gojo's last moments but instead
feel sympathy for him to which Gojo
thanks to Nami for it here is himself he
also asked what it was like in an army
but you jumps in revealing that man
actually made his own appearance during
the nami's passing an army also drops
another bomb revolving around sorcery as
according to him curses sometimes even
help keep people alive in regards to
Gojo's question an army answers there he
had once asked Maison about where to
head in the afterlife and she suggested
to either move north if you were looking
for a new side of yourself or move South
if you want to stay who you are I think
it's fairly evident just looking at all
the other vengeful curses we've seen
that naoya probably took the northern
path and this also finally lets us know
that it's a bit more straightforward if
someone does actually want to watch
achieve vengeful curse State I'd imagine
the consequences that come with it
though are probably reprehensible like
no afterlife or a cursed one that they
have to exist in when they do go back to
it anyways back to the sadness obviously
and I never expected any otherwise from
my dad an army says he chose South
without any doubt when the time came but
for a moment even gambled on a better
future his last moments and his eyes
went bad at all though thanks to his
best mate making his reappearance and
telling him what way to go lastly and
screaming out at the big masamichi Yaga
who instantly covers his ears to protect
himself Gojo jokingly mocks him for sane
earlier in life that there wasn't any
death Without Regrets as a sorcerer
obviously meaning that man probably
doesn't have any regrets right now
looking around at everyone else gathered
with him inside of the airport an army
you masato who toji must have sadly also
killed plus you know there is that
little ghostly figure in the back that
might actually be told you so that is
hilarious Rico as well who's there
masato and finally his best mate sugadu
Gojo then also cracks his best smile yet
and hopes to God that this isn't a dream
in reality Gojo who was just deemed the
strongest Sorcerer And Jujutsu Kaizen
history is shown to be in half and no
longer capable of breathing with his
eyes movement stopping and debate of his
heart ceasing saturu Gojo loses and rest
in peace big man it had to happen at
some point but thank you Giga it was
absolutely amazing the way it did happen
as dust particles then fall from above
blanketing the entire Battlefield sukuna
the king of curses explains what truly
happened under maharaja's adaption once
maharaga receives an attack from someone
it'll gradually adapt to it over time as
we saw with Gojo's technique some took
more spins than others but the more
attacks maharaga takes the faster it'll
adapt that sitability even after it
adapts it will further analyze the
technique and continue to do even more
depictions tsukuna says he expected
maharaga to be an example to him an
example which passed through Gojo's
infinity and showed him how to do it
himself throughout the battle maharaga
was first adapting to Gojo's Infinity
then it would change its own cursed
energy over time so that it could
neutralize Gojo's Infinity the second
time maharaga adapted was exactly what
he expected it wasn't the same as sakuna
slash technique instead it expanded the
target for the acoustic technique more
specifically expanded the target of the
slash to not just Gojo but this space
the world and then cut it in front of
sukuna now it's evident that there is no
physical way Gojo is going to be able to
recover as he has been completely
disembodied by zacona's technique slash
sakuna explains that Infinity doesn't
matter as a technique if the world
exists the world will be divided it
doesn't matter if Gojo or even his
Infinity exists they will be sliced
sukuna note that it was difficult for
him to pull Loft but a great example for
him to work on bringing Gojo's watch to
fruition sukuna with a fat smile on his
face then thanks him for the Magnificent
battle while saying that he will never
ever forget about him turning and seeing
someone approaching him at a high speed
now sukuna tells them that he better not
let him down flashing into the sky we
see that without any time for anyone to
mourn or feel sorry for Gojo's death the
one that came in to take his place
against the king of curses was no one
other than the Thunder God Hajime
hashimo
and what an amazing fight that was all
the cope I've seen from Gojo fans since
the spoilers Trump is actually honorable
but I don't see any way or any like
possible Universe of him even getting
back up anytime soon I'm curious as to
how fast Kona will be able to take his
technique and what he will do with Gojo
possibly take his own body in the future
that would be extremely interesting I
highly doubt it but I do truly feel bad
for shoko and ajichi now as they are the
only two from Gojo's time in school to
like still be around I hope they make it
through somehow throughout the rest of
the story but who knows at the moment I
love this freaking battle man and I
think it was fairly obvious that from
day one Gojo was most likely going to
lose this just for the narrative we need
our goats Yuji and you to actually
running the series and being the ones to
finish it not their teacher it's time to
let them shine and I can't wait to see
them start growing in actual strength
like Yuji might finally get his own
technique who knows anyways if you guys
have enjoyed the video and want to see a
bunch of stuff just like this but for a
variety of different series do remember
to subscribe also leave a like and try
and push this video to 10K likes plus
let me know your thoughts on everything
that just happened in the skyjo versus
Kona battle and some other fights or
series if you want me to cover them in
the future either way for now it's been
your professional to generate dear Volo
and I will see you all in eight Birds
bye